[Music]
hey guys now some of you asked me hey
daniel how can i get rid of acne scars
and marks on my face not the pimples
themselves but the marks they leave
behind now i got to be honest and you
have to know this that the marks that
pimples leave behind is tough it is
tougher to deal with than the pimples
themselves and the time it takes for
these marks to go away it will take time
and it depends on four things
number one your skin type number two the
age and depth of your marks number three
treatment
number four your ability to heal so the
truth is that it will take time
patience and consistency from your part
for your skin to improve and even though
you can make your skin look better over
time with the right treatment you need
to understand that it might be difficult
for those deep scars
to be normal again so that being said
here's a few tips that you can do to get
rid of acne marks and scars let's start
with number one
[Applause]
prevention yeah i made prevention one of
the tips because it really is so
important
most people get shocked when they start
to get a lot of pimples especially in
their teen years or even early 20s and
then they don't know how to deal with it
and then of course over time the scars
come so what you want to do is you want
to prevent it from happening in the
first place
how do you do that well you do that by
using a good skin care routine to take
care of the pimples of your acne now
this is still new to you and you don't
know what products you can trust i use
geology which is amazing because they
customize your products to take care of
your unique skin concerns
you just go to their website
answer a few questions about your skin's
condition
then they put the ingredients together
and send it directly to your house easy
as a then you just use the skincare
routine in the morning and at night
first you wash it
[Applause]
then you use the daytime moisturizer or
the nighttime moisturizer depending on
the time of day
[Music]
home remedies let's talk about it for a
second here
there's a lot of videos out there that's
just not true at all
people have mixed feelings about it some
say it works some say nah it doesn't
work let's talk about the post acne
marks first before we talk about the
scars when it comes to home remedies my
advice is to stay away from at home
remedies like rubbing lemon juice or any
other kind of fruits on your face they
just don't work because they can't
penetrate deep enough into the skin they
can't exfoliate your skin and the worst
part is that some of these fruits are
actually dangerous like lemon
because of the acidity in them meaning
they are strong skin sensitizers and
they can make those post acne marks look
even worse and stay there for longer
that's definitely not what you want
but you can try aloe vera that might be
better for your skin but do your own
research on it now let's talk about the
scars when it comes to home remedies
first you need to understand what these
scars are your scars are permanent
indentations in your skin because of the
damage of collagen and i gotta be honest
the scars are extremely difficult to
deal with unless you do chemical peels
and lasers but i'll talk about that a
little bit later on now are there
certain home remedies that you can try
out well yes you can try manuka oil
frankincense vetiver helichrysum coconut
oil aloe vera shea butter and onion
extract oh yeah before i forget remember
to subscribe to my channel if you like
my content just subscribe here click the
notification bell as well so youtube
will notify you whenever i upload a new
video i would love to support now let's
move on to the next step
[Applause]
use the right skincare products now
you've probably tried a few products and
from personal experience most people
realize that most products don't do what
you hope that they will do
so what you can do
is to educate yourself on the
ingredients within products this will
help you to choose the right products
and use the right skincare routine
research shows that a non-irrotating
cleanser a salicylic acid exfoliant
and benzoyl peroxide can definitely
improve your skin from acne marks and
scars
then you can also check out products
with skin restoring ingredients like
retinol and then vitamin c and
antioxidants will also help now this is
all new to you don't worry i've got you
covered i've added my best options of
products for you in the video
description down below so you can go and
check it out
[Music]
abrasive scrubs stop using it right now
it's not going to make it better if you
use abrasive scrubs
acne marks and acne itself cannot just
be scrubbed away in fact if you use it
it's definitely just going to make
things worse
why because then you're just going to
aggravate your skin causing inflammation
just making things worse causing more
damage and it's going to take longer for
you to heal so when you take a shower
when you take a bath just use your hands
to clean your face gently with the right
cleanser
[Music]
sunscreen if you are out and about in
the sun all the time with your acne
breakouts unprotected then the rays of
the sun will actually damage your skin
even more let me explain this in a
simple way
your breakouts your acne those those
marks right it's already got a color in
it when you tan in the sun
you get browner right
when you have those marks and the sun
hits it day after day after day
is going to get worse it's going to stay
there for longer so just an easy fix
don't stay in the sun too long and if
you go into the sun use the right
skincare products i personally use
geology which is specifically made for
the skin of your face
[Music]
leave your pimples alone
again prevention is always better than
treatment afterwards you got to stop
picking at scratching at popping those
pimples just leave them alone if you
pick at your pimples it is going to
leave you with scars
i know sometimes you have to do it when
you have a very big event and it's
important
to look
your best then you got to do it but you
have to do it the right way and listen
carefully if you have problematic skin
you know skin that is in with a lot of
pimples that's inflamed there's big red
ones if you pop that if you scratch that
then they are a lot more likely to leave
you with scars so please try not
to peek at or pop those pimples
[Music]
pmd
have you ever heard of it do you know
what it is
it stands for
personal microderm system so what is it
well it's basically a personalized
microderm abrasion treatment that you
can do at home you know a lot of people
actually use this weekly to get rid of
those fine lines you know getting older
for blemishes and also for enlarged
pores but it's also great for those post
acne marks and for the scars now again
gotta be honest with you guys i've never
used it myself personally i've done a
lot of research on it i've
seen a lot of people comment on it
and most people are really happy with it
again i'll add it in the video
description so you can do your own
research
[Music]
now if you've tried out all of these
tips and you're still not happy go and
see a dermatologist they are
professional they know what they're
talking about go and hear them out
they're probably going to recommend
chemical peels and lasers but they might
also give you some other good options as
well now if you guys want to see my
skincare routine for clear skin check
out this video here and i'll see you
there and before you go always remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys